this morning with America's rising voice
the call for racial equality and police
reform in small towns and big cities
protests against police tactics and
violence pressed on for another night
memorials for George Floyd both formal
and informal continued to stretch across
the world this morning marches are
happening in places like London and
Australia tens of thousands of people
are calling for real change in policies
and policing that protect people of
color Jamie yuccas is in Minneapolis
this morning where excessive use of
force by police will no longer be
tolerated Jamie good morning good
morning Michelle I'm standing in front
of the Minneapolis Police Department's
third Precinct that went up in flames
last week anger boiled over after the
killing of George Floyd here in
Minneapolis his death has shined a light
on generations of systemic racism
yesterday an emergency meeting at the
Minneapolis City Council agreed with the
state to make sweeping changes including
banning the use of choke holds in
Minneapolis the memorial site still
lives where George Floyd died after a
white police officer held him down with
in need of a neck now the protesters
calls for change are being heard on
Friday in a virtual meeting the City
Council voted to ban the use of neck
restraints they're also requiring
officers who witness unauthorized use of
force to report it from the scene and
intervene verbally and physically I will
say that George Floyd's death weighs
heavily on me and I know every elected
official in Minneapolis we could have
done more and we should have done more
the protesters have asked for the police
department to be defunded yes do you
think that should happen
I have long supported shifting funds
away from our Police Department into
community-based strategies I think our
police department needs dramatic
structural change and that we need a
whole new way of doing Public Safety in
our city in Buffalo New York near City
Hall two officers involved in shoving a
75 year old protester to the ground
causing serious injury were suspended
without pay
you see that video and it disturbs your
basic sense of decency and humanity when
I saw the video I got sick to my stomach
but now in solidarity with the suspended
officers all 57 members of buffalos
emergency response team have resigned
from the unit that responds to crowd
control situations but not from the
force everyone peacefully protesting in
the City of Buffalo will be protected
while in the country's capital on Friday
DC Mayor Muriel Bowser had black lives
matter painted on the street to honor
protesters who demanded an end to police
brutality and renamed a street leading
to the White House black lives matter
plaza in a letter the mayor urged
President Trump to withdraw National
Guard troops brought in days ago when
some protests turned violent
Friday he doubled down on his decision
you have to dominate the streets you
can't let what's happening happen
it's called dominate the street later
President Trump slammed Bowser on
Twitter calling her incompetent you know
the thing about the pot and the kettle
another big change in police policy here
in Minneapolis before officers can use
crowd control weapons like tear gas and
rubber bullets the chief or his designee
must approve its use officer Derek
shavon will be in court on Monday Jeff
Jamie thing